garrett richards has taken the field
along with his teammates 32 year old
making his seventh start of the season
bases are loaded
that will bring up kyle seger
[Applause]
fly ball into left field pro far circles
underneath it crawford tags and makes
his way home and he is safe seeger's
sack fly meriters on the board four
batters into things one nothing
that'll bring up first baseman jose
marmaleo's
tattooed
out towards right center and gone grand
slam
jose marmaleos is digging san diego
two two-run homer in game one
and now a grand slam in game two shed
long junior eighth batter this inning
shed the opposite way this is carrying
back this is on its way and going off
the ribbon board
shed long junior showing some oppo pop
shed the dh this afternoon
kikuchi on the mound here for
the seattle mariners in game two
in the air to left field it's deep it's
far and that ball is gone
the bottom basket of the western metal
supply company building machado with his
third home run of the day two in game
one
and his first home run of game two gets
the padres on the board
[Music]
[Applause]
this the right field that's going to get
in for a base hit back to the wall
and cronenworth will be stopped at third
in the second base with a double ghost
ty france and the padres with one out
have runners at second and third second
and third with one out and jerks and
profar
ground ball chopped towards third base
kyle seeger racing in his throw to first
base his wild run scores and taking
third is ty france
so profar will reach the padres get
another run it's six to two now mariners
there's a swing and a miss and striking
out is austin nola
third strikeout for
luis perdomo since coming in one down in
the inning
swinging a miss and he struck him out
back-to-back strikeouts for luis perdomo
two down in the inning
swinging a miss san perdomo does a very
nice job works his way around a lead off
double
[Applause]
swinging a miss for strike three
strikeout number five for kikuchi pitch
fastball swung on a miss struck him out
so kukuchi with strikeout number six
looks like jorge mateo is going to pinch
it for austin hedges here's the 2-2
pitch
that's well struck out towards the right
center field gap going back is lopes he
will not get there and it will hop over
the fence for a rule book double oh
mateo's first major league hit is a
double and had it not hopped over the
fence it was easily going to be a triple
usa set at the belt first pitch to manny
swung on bounce to third secret nice hop
throws to second for one over the first
double play
kochi pitches out of it in the fifth we
go to the sixth the mariners lead at six
to three
that is ball four and down to first base
goes myers back-to-back walks allowed by
fletcher here in the sixth inning tying
run at the plate in jake cronin work
here's the pitch out of the way breaking
ball swing and a miss by cronin work for
strike three one down for ty france
lying to right field lopes coming in and
that's in for a base hit hosmer will
take third as lopes gets it back in
quickly and
an errant throw and it will get away but
it is backed up
as fletcher the pitcher backs up that
throw from right field but the padres
have him loaded now with one down on the
second hit in this game for ty france
naylor pinch [ __ ] quick round ball
to first marmalades to throw oh they got
him at home
marmalayos gets to the ball steps on the
bag throws to the plate
to get hosmer
and that will retire the side that's how
you get a double play one of the most
unusual double plays we've seen
hagerty parks another base hit this time
into right field it's a multi-hit game
for sam hagerty the mariners do play a
little add-on
hagerty into double clap into second
clapping his hands as jp crawford scores
at 7-3
noah has walked a couple of times and
struck out all for one here in game two
hard hit and a center field for a base
hit
hagerty scores it's 8-3 mariners mateo
on it third machado on at first base
with two outs
and here is eric hosmer
in play
to hirano
a little skee-ball toss to first and the
mariners win game two of the
double-header mike and they take the
series two games to one